okay hello everyone welcome to another
design review wolf language design
review
language completeness and consistency
a variety of topics
all right the first one is a
sophisticated and complicated topic
that i'm surprised is first on the list
here
uh well that's because we have invited
several people including
folks from the european time zone so
i wanted that to be first
um
uh
the right so they're they're they're um
you know
obviously this is a big topic that can
go in a number of ways um
last time we talked about this new data
structure called experstruct i don't
know if
there's something that isn't
tom yeah it is this 13 type dollar
version
i'm sorry
what
he wants to know if you're or he wants
to know what what build you're using so
he's asking you to evaluate dollar
version um just a second i'm seeing
something that's wrong here hold on one
second
oh dear
um
okay
uh i'm sure that i'm running i'm not
running um
just type dollars
we don't
yeah
no we don't need the prototype build
but we just need to know that it's a
reason enough okay so that's you're
right now
you're not running yeah i know i know
that's uh because i wasn't thought okay
a head branch build is that correct yeah
head branch is great
has startup gotten slower
i think so
yes it has
we better fix this can somebody um
avery can you make sure that that's
taken to qa
and that we try and figure out what's
going on there
yep i got a note of that
okay right so type create data structure
yeah that looks good correct data
structure
and then extra struct
probably the documentation is behind
which is why it's not and then give it
give it the initial value like
list one comma two
yep here we go
right
so now you can do normal of that or
well what can i do that's more
interesting with this i mean so if i
do do one comma two
let's make something that we want to
stop evaluating
so do the list
can i feed this a hold or or not
you could you could put hold around this
yes to hold of no no i understand that
but what happened
one plus one plus two
okay but what i'm asking is is there a
way to do a create data structure wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait where i
give it
just one plus two without the hold there
no what i'm saying
okay so we could do that i mean
you could you could do unevaluated
presumably
wouldn't bank on it
okay
well that's okay so that's what happened
well let's try it that would be an
interesting you should try it see what
happens okay but let's see what tom was
wanting us to do here right so now do
say like parts or or do you replay
make that back into list one comma two
great
and then
take that output
and do replace parts the operation yeah
which one
replacement that's right percent
percent
bracket yup yup great bracket
replace part zero goes to plus
and that's made a new data structure
that's plus
okay how do i get out the held version
of that
uh full form would would get given no no
no no no i want to get a hold of blah
blah blah out if i say normal i'd get
back then you could do
percent five construct with
hold that was the function we made so
make another one
and then do okay but that's not what i
want because i want something where i
just get out the held version
yeah fine okay we we we don't we we
could make something right so we should
make that i mean we should make that
what do you want to call that yeah yeah
that's that's a good idea held
expression or something we call it we
have one that's called expression which
is the same as normal and one's called
held expression
that's that's that's great
[Music]
okay
and then on the way in we need some way
to really you know
be able what one thing we're going to
need is a way to take a front end
something that i've just entered like
you know whatever it is you know
um
you know something like this right that
i've entered in the front end right and
get that into a data structure
how would i do that
so i'm i'm
don't quite understand well can you can
you
try create data structure with uh with
unevaluated and see what happens yes but
i'm i'm saying i'm saying there needs to
be some mechanism that's going to come
up quite a bit you've got code that is
in some that is in a notebook for
example and i want to make an ast from
it for example you get what i'm saying
i get what you're saying um
so maybe there needs to be a thing that
reads the book hold on hold on we talked
about this it's not just create data
structure there's loads of things
there's like you know saving into a file
there's writing over math link there's
creating json you know all of these
things it's the same problem so maybe we
should have a uniform
way to yes solve it that's not that's
what we're talking about
some special
feature for example so let's talk about
all these different cases i mean right
right what we're saying is you've now
got
a kernel-level version of the
experstruct
correct that you can work with as an
expression right so what we need to know
is how do you get into and out of that
that thing
is what i'm saying
so actually first thing i should do
getting out of it you just suggested
good idea expression and held expression
i think those those are great ideas okay
so what is this
well that's the full form of the thing
like everything you know serializable
into
the full form
i see so this is simply
actually that's just data arrow whatever
and there might be some
extra structure that's just
right
right i mean it's basically a fake full
form right so that
it's right
because if you go out
and it'll recreate the data structure
well it will recreate well it yes but
it's it's but it's a right
of the it's a serialization okay all
right so let's talk about where this
goes into and where it comes out of so
to speak
okay
so
you want to be able to take this
and routinely make from this data
structure you want to be able to write
it to a file
you know for example
i want to be able to trivially get
from my plus thing here
from this line five i want to be able to
trivially get that to come out in a
notebook as one plus two
and that's the problem i want to be able
to
to have that
be written in a notebook is one plus two
i wanted to write it to a file as one
plus two i wanted to write it to w stp
is one plus two is that correct
right yes we want all those things to
happen correct right but so in
particular i want to be able to take
this data structure and i want to be
able to
do those things with it without turning
it into normal again
and without having the data structure
wrapper be around the things that come
out
right
right
but well i mean
in some contexts you might want that but
right obviously you can't want that in
general or
no i mean it won't save to the notebook
yeah okay but but
what you want
okay
listen
the thing is is
you know
it has a it
you know it's a multi-personality
creature
right on the one hand it is data
structure of whatever a fully
you know
inertified structural object
okay
on the other hand it is the expression
that is represented by that am i making
sense
so for some purposes you want it to
behave like the expression and for some
purposes you want it behavior like the
full structural data structure am i
correct
well i i no i don't i don't agree with
that and i don't think christopher would
either right he was pointing out how
dangerous having this multi-personality
is
no i so okay listen listen listen
think of it okay i i'm saying it wrong
by having multiple personalities
i'm saying that
you need to be able to when you deliver
it into a notebook or into a file or
whatever you need to be able to
deliver it having stripped the data
structure wrapper
you see what i'm saying um
well
um maybe but but i don't i don't uh
um
i mean i suppose we could have some
uh
right i mean i well
i i i'm not sure i really see how that's
possible right i mean i i don't know i
don't know
don't tell me something
i will tell you that it's impossible
stephen if i think it's impossible okay
but i mean
if
either it's a data structure or it's a
normal expression
it stays it stays a data structure and
the moment you extract it right it's
going to go into the event calculator
and exactly exactly right exactly
that's correct unless it doesn't go to
the evaluator because it goes to a file
wstp a notebook
you know a notebook cell or any of those
other things that don't go to the
evaluator
see what i'm saying what do you mean no
no book cells don't go to the evaluator
of course
you can you can i understand if you
press shift enter they go to the
evaluator but i would no
in order to get into the notebook they
have to go through the kernel which of
course is going through the evaluator
okay that's why we've got a problem here
but remember things like defer for
example defer
does something goes through the
evaluator i understand but look what it
did it made an expression that i can
copy here
and put in a there
and it is the raw expression
so i'm saying when i when i run it
through the evaluator it does that but
what i'm saying is what we need is
something where from the data structure
it is very straightforward
to
you know
to do two things
one
let's say i've got a notebook and i want
to do code analysis on the notebook okay
the thing i'm going to want to do is to
take the cells in the notebook that have
things like this in them and immediately
turn them into data structures
before before it enters my code i never
want to see this i want to see it as a
data structure
see what i'm saying
even though stored in the notebook just
like stored in a file it is the raw
ascii characters
does that make sense
possibly
um
so stephen cosby right i mean right
i i mean right i mean but right the this
would not be a right but that would not
be a function that's tied to data
structure i don't think right i'm not
sure right now
let me finish my sentence stephen
right it's because right the
only right the reason right defer
evaluates to itself right and then it
has typeset rules that basically tell it
to
types it as if it weren't there
right and so you could do something like
right have some sort of notebook level
function that takes the cells in the
notebook and does make expression on all
of them and then
feeds that write make expression returns
things wrapped and hold complete so
you could then take the right you could
turn that into a data structure and
delete the overall hold complete or
maybe you directly feed the contents
into
of the whole complete into a data
structure whichever way you want okay
you know
before we tangle that that's down in the
implementation can we talk about what we
want to achieve
because okay let's just look at a few
things we want to achieve
so for example something like this not
sure it's the right exact syntax
but you see that this would make some
sense
right important
just like it's held expressions
yes it probably would be like extra
straps i mean
yeah it probably should be okay so the
extra structure this structure is
slightly special i think so
okay expert struct expert structure i
don't know okay uh the but but you get
what the functionality would be
right
right it would return a list of data
structures that are then completely
frozen right you don't have to worry
about things blowing up on you or
anything
this is taking a file and it's just
reading it as extra structs
i'm suggesting
that
you know my question now
is things like get
um
yeah let me just don't put this in the
right place where should i put this well
get is inherently i don't think get is
in part of the story because get is
inherently reading one expression and
then evaluating it before going on to
get i agree all right okay okay
transformation folder
code transformation thank you
okay
so
all right i'm i'm admitting on on get
that isn't well okay get as a question
mark as far as i'm concerned because i
could imagine something like get
that would okay so the question is is
there
a
sort of an extra struct get okay a file
dot
wl
okay which would return
am i crazy here
yeah i think i
think is a little bit like brenton's
code analysis does does things like that
yeah i know i know i know that's what
i'm asking for i know you know so right
it's something that brings it in but the
whole point is that a get will run all
the lines in the file and then return
the last one so really one wants an
import type thing instead
yeah correct
so
um
you know i'm just wondering
whether there's sort of an analog this
is not the right name but just like we
have binary serialize
is that crazy where you're taking an
expression
and you're turning it into this binary
form right
binary serialize of of uh you know one
two three or whatever
okay
right well i think it's i think that's
going right i think serialize
is right well i don't think we should
use serialized serialize but i think in
particular right binary serialize is
going the opposite way right it's
taking an expression and and turning it
into this other thing and we're talking
right we want we import obviously solves
the problem of how to take expressions
from a file and turn them into extra
structs
um and make yes and maybe we want a two
expert struct which is the equivalence
of this basically
right and we can make that one hold
first and
you know then you can literally just
type in
what uh what you want i agree
that seems sensible to have that behold
first
because that that would be okay so now
the question is
i'm
okay let's go through more some more use
cases okay i'm looking at this cell in
the notebook
how do i take that cell in the notebook
and
let's say i've got a button that's a
code analysis button somewhere okay the
first thing it wants to do is take the
box form of that cell
and
turn it into an expert
right well which is right i mean if we
have two expert struct that's super
simple right we make expression the cell
and then we apply to expert struct
to that expression to the hold complete
that comes out of make expression
well you're saying a different thing
there which is you're saying that too
expect could strip
the alternative would be that two x's no
no no i said no no i i literally meant
apply as in the function apply
right we replace the head hold complete
with two extra struct
and
so i i i would like to make an argument
that perhaps two extracts should not be
hold first but one should routinely put
held expressions into it
that that will be more flexible
um
what's that we're unevaluated yes no no
no unevaluated is a horrendous hack
it really is you know you feel as
unevaluated as i feel about sequence
i i i'm with you on sequence as well
okay all right anyway um so but uh but i
want to walk through this workflow a
little bit more carefully because i
don't think this is quite right yet okay
so so let's let's understand okay let's
look at what one would do
see i just feel like okay i don't even
go ahead
i i well i just want to say i mean right
you know i'll be channeling christopher
here and say right i mean in order for
the for 2x per struct to be safe for
code transformations it can't be
changing the expression so
we i think we want it to be hold first
okay that's a fair point
and i mean basically the implementation
of that is
create data structure
express struct hold of blah and then
take the first part
yes that's what it is that's all it is
so you could implement it even as we
speak
um
okay so out of curiosity yeah steven for
your use case of selecting something in
the notebook and then having it
come in as an expert
expert struct
what would you expect to happen if what
you have selected is not
you know semantically
i think it has to be an error
what's that
i said it beeps
okay just checking yeah
okay but so so one of the points is that
right now we have command shift e
which gives us you know that kind of
thing right
i'm just trying to think about how one
would actually do this you know how
i you know we need to have a meeting
about the modernization of the notebook
programming functions which is certainly
going to be related to this i mean
well it's well right i mean it's pretty
straightforward right it's cells of cell
style goes to input to grab all the
input cells
in your current notebook
and then you notebook read this
resulting cell objects and do whatever
you want with those expressions like
applying make expression
well the cell object
and make expression you know i never use
these things make expression gives a
whole complete version of it is that
correct
uh
yes yes
all right well we should we should see
that workflow but that doesn't sound
obviously hopeless i mean it's a little
bit multi-step
and i'm kind of wondering
i'm kind of wondering if you're writing
a button
don't we have things like paste button
and and copy button and things like that
which
will take the selection and do things to
them
see what i'm saying
you know what i'm talking about
yeah and i'm wondering whether we could
we could use those
that's not the right one
what's one way you
where you take the selection
what about the inactivate button don't
we have something like that
yeah we have well do we i mean we have
what do we have here we have a right
click
we don't but we could have something
like that
we could have just like we have i can
eyes here
which by the way is so useful it really
should get much promoted in this menu
that's a avery that's a note for a
different for the user system
okay got it that's that's like the for
me that's the most used thing in this
right click menu is i can eyes on i can
eyes what about other people
oh well i mean i would almost always use
the keyboard shortcut um
or if that's which which i don't know
what it is because annoyingly it's not
in the right click menu
which is another one
no yeah we've been through this stephen
this is the correct behavior on mac
uh it's control but it's control command
period
control sorry control command single
control command single quote
what do you know
cool
i think i think if you go
i think if you go to the edit menu i
think it has the keyboard shortcut
yes it does yes
well there isn't something useful here
okay but any case the thing i was gonna
what i'm trying to say is
you are trying to make a button that
takes this as an extra struct what is
the best way to do that
if you if you try to make a button that
will just wrap a function around this
there's a nice way to see
i mean right there there's notebook
selection which
you know you can notebook read notebook
selection
to get the express you know the cell
expression and then you can
you know then you can proceed from there
with you know make expression
right well so you believe
i'm still
claiming that there's a more direct path
that we might that we should provide but
any case that's at least a part yeah
right there's right i mean there's like
copy to clipboard
right so there are things for getting
things to and from the clipboard i don't
know that there's a function that
directly
creates a button and there's click to
copy obviously
i mean i think you know
with like notebook apply or something or
see there's another case let's take
click to copy
okay
let's imagine
yes click to copy is a good example
okay so let's walk through that click to
copy wants to click wants to copy code
like it wants to copy something like one
plus two doesn't want to copy the three
in other words if the click to copy
you you fed something in to click to
copy
okay
so here
okay but this is not hold first is it
oh i see click to copy defer
creates a button that displays and
copies is the unevaluated form
um
right because these are both type
setting constructs so right this all
happens at type setting time and not at
the valuation time
okay so this then becomes a click to
copy of that
which is that
okay so what i'm trying to make sure of
is that if you have generated a data
structure
inside that you know you've done code
transformations
and
then you're making the click to copy be
that transformed code that there's a
fairly quick path
from
the thing you have is that data
structure
to so so
what okay so here's the missing thing i
think i think what we need is something
where
effectively it isn't quite this but
defer of data structure does the right
thing
see what i'm saying we need something
that will unpack the data structure well
so so one way to do that would simply be
to have just as we said that there will
be a held expression
okay so we could say held expression
and we could also say deferred
expression
you see what i'm saying and that would
be the equivalent of defer of
the extracted expression from the data
structure
right so so basically i mean
this is maybe a little bit too into the
weeds but right we could have something
that
right extracts the held expression
replace it and then
returns that's an implementation right
yes
but i mean but do you agree that the
point here would be
that this would allow you to go from the
data structure to a thing that walks and
talks like
you know
this
is the front end
i think that's a useful thing
okay
so
uh
okay sandra is commenting on the right
click menu that we could remove cut copy
paste and so on
yeah we should um
well certainly not copy as i know i know
that is the item i use the most from the
right click menu
okay
we need to review the right click menus
different meeting that's the user
assistance meeting let's get an item
there to do that yeah
um i i
right i want to
shift direction a little bit and point
to sort of the two first two
sub-sections in the agenda i'm happy to
do that but can i just ask in the chat i
put some a couple of things can can you
just paste them in stephen yes i can but
i'm going to comment on something sander
has said in the live stream and then i
want to look at these
sandra is saying
but not look for those because they are
shortcuts
get help
could show up when something is selected
um
you mean
i think you might be talking about the
idea of operator
well not not the sele the selection
wraps
idea that when we select something
we right right now we have the hover
racks yes but we also talked about you
select something and then something
shows up that's a good idea
that's for you which has been
right i mean
and that's something that's been
discussed and and sort of some planned
features are waiting for that to be
implemented right okay um all right tom
okay yes evaluate that now do normal of
that
percent normal
right so e-type i think that was
something you wanted i don't know if you
still want it or maybe i was confused
but
you wanted to do math but evaluate
things in a held expression then that's
doing that well it's just one of a
million different
potential functions that directly work
on
expert structs right
okay so
i i agree that's something that is
sometimes wanted but i don't understand
why that works
um but what it's doing is it's just
taking out takes out the one it
maps the function you know it does a map
and evaluates that and then inserts it
into the output
so it doesn't rely so
it evaluates things as it goes along not
it's explicitly calling eval rather than
relying on eval of the result
i have a question
which
i thought you wanted that you you said
you wanted that last time we i'm sure
but maybe i misunderstood you
i think i think you misunderstood uh
well
that this is actually a good segue to to
our next point but yeah i'm not sure
this is right because this is so
different from what function map does
well that's why someone said because it
is slightly different it is different
well then but what what is the
difference here the difference here
right if you
see it's quite useful actually to
evaluate the thing as it's as it's being
mapped okay so hold on hold on hold on
all right so so so
this is a good this is this is a good
segue to the second so look at that yes
you've already got this discussion
okay right
so if you oh there's uh if you open the
subs actual subsection not just the
bullet points up top
um
right so relationship between
and we'll get
that thing there
yep
um and maybe i collapsed this a bit too
much uh i guess i must have just
collapsed all subsections
um right so
with rule and rule delayed
um
right they you bind the variables but
you don't evaluate
you you rely on sort of the the the
evaluator kicking in and doing further
evaluate so you know this is something
we certainly want sometimes
you know a rule delayed evaluate that
you know
matches
uh
then evaluates the right-hand side and
sticks that in instead of which is a
sort of a version i guess of what tom
did here with map
um
sorry i'm confused so hold on i'm
confused
that okay
the point is
there's a question that there's several
times at which evaluation can happen
either
standard rule delayed just puts in there
as we saw happen here in a different
context
you know well that that's
that's uh yet another issue so so
change that type in the following
replace
hold of one two
x blank goes to x blank squared
or x squared yes at level one
okay right so so you see there it
actually right it bound the x and then
it yeah i get it again
right i get it and there's no way in
here to say i want this evaluated on
impact so to speak
well well that's
well that there are two different issues
one is that
i mean there's the slash semi-trick but
there there certainly isn't a simple way
to say i want this
evaluated on impact
there's no wrapper that would allow one
to say here
like what we've discussed previously i
think you know immediate evaluate
right so one idea was the immediate
evaluate wrapper which we could reuse in
multiple different functions and the
other idea was to have a new type of
rule which we called rule delayed
evaluate and we hadn't sort of
switched you know made a decision on
which way was the better way to go
i don't like having another kind of rule
because i think otherwise if we're going
to have an entrance form we're going to
use some up characters and it's um
i think
has rules i mean like map you could use
media to evaluate in in map and there's
no rule in map
yeah right you could do map yeah like
your example you have an example you
have examples very time like that yep
that that would i like the concept of
immediate value it seems useful and that
one and then here what would happen is
well then we'd have immediate evaluate
around the function
well
the basic point
here would be you could do something
more general
hold on hold on hold on hold on
is immediate evaluator function though
yes
no it would have to be understood by the
outer yeah
it doesn't it's not a function how do
you put a pure function into that no no
no no no no just just i'm just gonna say
immediately
you do nothing just like nothing does
nothing
right nothing there does nothing right
immediate evaluate will be another
symbolic indicator that does nothing or
or supply do whatever we call it does
nothing
and i don't mean nothing in the sense of
nothing i mean only does something in
math and replacement things i'm sorry
correct it only does something in map
and replace right and so
well and really it's a it's really an
indicator to map and replace if you do
something special it doesn't supply
anything itself it's not a function it's
a wrapper around so you could put a pure
function inside immediate evaluate yep
sure correct
that's correct
that's correct is it
yes
fine good right okay i like this idea
because i think i think we have
pioneered this notion
of of sort of
things that in an environment do
something and we've had that forever but
but nothing is a good example of
something which in an environment does
something and otherwise
i'm just confusing myself does nothing
so to speak
but you get what i'm saying you
understand what i'm saying so right
immediate evaluate would be a sign just
like supplied is assigned to a function
to do a particular thing
this seems very sensible to me
now an interesting question is whether a
hold first function
could take an immediate evaluate
well i don't think
you know in other words could hold
well first you can just use evaluate
right
i mean
withhold you can just use evaluate right
i see and why can't you do that in the
cases we're talking about here
because
um
evaluate is magic in the evaluator that
correct it correct
it sort of right forces evaluation
based on attributes it would also be
difficult to write code that includes me
immediately evaluate if it immediately
evaluated
right right
yes
okay so the point is that this
maybe the name immediately isn't right i
mean this
is immediate evaluation
evaluate is it okay so the basic point
is evaluating
is immediate evaluation
for the evaluator for
for
overriding
hold attributes in the evaluator
right which which is what happened here
i mean it didn't really make it didn't
make a visible difference in the result
but but you know that x squared was
fully evaluated as opposed to
symbolically being an unevaluated
it's also slightly more subtle than that
too because i mean if you do map with
the function with immediate evaluate
um
you know it may
it may actually you know since it
evaluates every time map evaluates the
function
it may wind up taking a lot less memory
in some cases for example if the the
expression is big but then it collapses
on evaluation to something small
right
i i think we under well
i think we understand what immediate
evaluate does now
the the point where where tom
misunderstood what ian and i were
arguing for is this immediate substitute
which is covered just you know in the
next little section
right and so
right if you use replace because you
bind directly to variables you can
you sort of right you immediately
stick in what you want
whereas
we don't really have
an equivalent of that for
map where
you know you want to sort of fill in
the the slots but you don't want the
main evaluation to take place
and i know maybe that's enough of an
edge case that we but
certainly something
but exactly
right so if you want right if you wanted
to see their one squared and two squared
like we got with replace there's
currently no way to do that using well
let me point out that you might want
that if you want to then wrap and
inactivate around the whole thing
sure because
you know
right so okay so the cases you're
talking about are
okay cases here are
immediately
okay so wait a minute a second so we've
got
immediately bind things
and
uh
patterns
are always immediately bound
immediately substituted
right
but yep
function variables
are not
immediately
what's that
they are i think
not if you're it requires one level of
evaluation of the function application
what they're talking about tom is just
using
i function versus using you know
uh evaluating that includes i function
see this does not work so if i say hold
if i say this
that's if i say hold a function
what am i what should i do here x x plus
one
well you want to map x expo you want to
map that function across
you know the list or across hold of one
two three
right you might expect to see one plus
one two plus one three plus one but
instead you see
and if you force evaluation you'll get
two three four but you won't be able to
get one plus one two plus one three plus
one okay as opposed to
the thing you were showing me up above
here where we say replace
this yep
x blank goes to x plus one level one
right and this is part of why
what did that just do
oh yes yes right it's substituted for
the x blank
yes yep
exactly and this is precisely why in
type setting code where we're
almost always dealing with uh you know
unevaluated expressions because we don't
want to change the meaning as we create
the output
um
right is why i use replace a lot more
than map precisely because i get this
immediate binding which i i can't get
right now using map
right okay so there's a
one situation
is immediate binding and the other
situation is
uh
immediately evaluate things
which is different from immediately bind
things
correct
okay so the case is there any other case
like for example how do templates work
how do they do binding
which of these cases are they doing for
binding
they
they use rules
i believe and if you use a rule delayed
you can if you do a expression template
okay so they use replacement semantics
not function semantics
for this binding yes i believe correctly
i believe that i believe so yes okay we
should check that but but i mean i i'm
pretty sure that's true actually
okay
and you can because you can
inject a held expression
by using
rule delayed which is quite useful
this is what i mean held expression you
can you can inject an expression okay so
i would like to point out that that
relates also to our expert discussion
because
what i'm saying is
you know if we're going to use extracts
a bunch one of the places we're going to
use them is like code construction
see what i'm saying
and then you might be juggling extra
structs all over the place
and then want to write them out in a
file
using the template functions
what i'm saying so so we've got a whole
discussion here about
you know
which we're not going to have right this
second but but um
uh
here
it's
how does
experstruct
play
with template functions
okay because i claim you're going to
need to auto unwrap
you can get what i'm saying you
understand what i'm saying
i understand what you're saying but
that's a
i mean
templates suggest another case of also
unwrapping things that we've been
struggling i know but but what we've got
so immediately buying things immediately
evaluate things
immediately
d extra struct things
yes yet different case
correct
it's another it's a another case yes
um
you know along with that
would be two expressioning of things
because that's something we're not able
to do
that is if you've got
what you mean not able to do
well
if you want to insert if you have a
string
i mean i guess these immediate evaluate
things would do that
if you have a string
and you want to and you're using that
string the stringified version of
something to keep it completely frozen
well maybe i don't know what i'm talking
about
i mean
immediately evaluate things also
immediately activate
but i guess you get that for free
if you if you've if you've got an
evaluation you can always put an
activate in there to activate things
yeah
okay so i don't know whether that makes
any sense though
okay so the proposals right now
are
some kind of immediate evaluate and
another immediate substitute
i don't think it should be called
substitute i think it should be called
immediate bind or something
immediate binding
possibly i mean
that sounds a bit better to me but i'm
not sure i can give you a reason other
than it sounds a bit better to me
uh oh that's a question from michael
sonny will this work on cloud expression
what is the relationship between
cloud expression and extra struct
there's no good reason that an expert
couldn't live in the cloud right that it
couldn't
that that well
i mean other than the fact that it's a
raw expression
i mean you could save a
a uh
uh a a you know uh
the the full form of an expert struct to
to to a cloud
you know to the cloud to a cloud object
but
right the actual expert right it's a raw
data structure
yes
but my question is instead
i don't know well i think the point is
that cloud expression already has the
feature that it doesn't just you know it
can't just evaluate a way
it's already a kind of a pinned
beetle so to speak well no that's a bad
analogy but you get what i'm saying it's
already something well it's it has it
has it has very restricted evaluation
semantics because it's right i i forget
what the new implementation is
uh
but it's right it's it's stored in right
in some external database right so my
question is so it's a good question what
the relationship between of experstruct
and that actually is
functionality-wise because we could
expect
that the operations that we do on cloud
expression on on
sorry on expert struct
would also be doable on cloud expression
and that's a good thing for us to make
sure we have consistency about
right tom you get what we're saying
sort of yes
what's the sort of i mean so just like
we say clear create cloud expression
just like we say create data structure
both of them are now capable of creating
expression structures
and so both of them have certain
operations you can do on them
and we need to make
sure that there's some consistency
between those
and there's a certain argument that with
cloud expression it already supports
i mean i don't know whether it's a good
thing but but um
okay
so it has a definite list
of operations that can be performed now
that's a different design pattern than
we're using for extra struct
see what i'm saying
it is yeah i mean some of the
permissions don't make any sense no no i
i know tom
i know i know
but there's an interesting possibility
here
that
i mean you know we knew in the design
that we did a few weeks ago of data of
the
expert struct data structure we knew
that was a defensive design that is we
we explicitly didn't decide we're going
to have actual
standard functions do things on extra
structs
right correct but we also said we
thought we might add that later and the
important point that
michael has been has made here is that
there is already a pattern a model for
this in cloud expression
yeah except i know but i mean
expert struct is a data structure so so
it should be following the conventions
of data streams i know but but hold on
there's nothing that says
we can't have something which is in fact
a data structure
and
it is able to be operated on like a data
structure but also
you know i mean the fact that it's
dressed as a data structure
i mean it's just like we have things i
think
that are dressed as data structures even
though they are in many ways just like
other expressions
but they are mutable in their data
structure form and so on well they they
may be mutable but they don't interact
that way
with right i mean
none of the data structures operate upon
right
you know can be operated upon as if
they're normal expressions
yes
and and so
you know
uh okay anyway look let's let's pin this
particular issue okay i think this is an
issue worth exploring but we don't have
to explore it a second
okay
um but please let's not lose that issue
as we go forward with the with the extra
concept
um
okay but i want to come back to this
so
what we've got
is
a function application so so what we've
got is the situation where
we have a function being applied
and it's inside
a hold
and the function is that only one case
of this
where the binding happens because
there's a sub value of the function
in other words
yeah the basic question is does the sub
code of the sub value run
because the sub value is only doing the
one thing of substitution
see what i'm saying
um
could immediate binding work with a
symbol and do
like a one-step evaluation using its
definitions or is that not a sensible
thing
well that's that's another issue right
that's another a completely different
issue right
so one-step evaluation of an owner if if
yeah is it the case that immediate
binding is really just one step eval
no i really don't think so very small i
mean i think that many other cases were
that's a different thing you're bringing
up one step evaluation of a known value
is interesting its own right but it
isn't
that's not the general case here
right and we don't i mean i don't think
we need that right because
the
right map isn't told anything so if
you're if you give it an f which has an
own value
um
yeah i mean i think i was thinking of
like a down value like do the do the
replacement for the first down value it
finds
evaluator is way too complicated to just
do that
yeah
okay but the case we're looking at here
is this
what we've got is some wrapper around a
function
applied to arguments
that will work
even if that's inside a hold
is that right yep
wow that's weird semantics oh no that's
that's crazy sorry
right well that's what we're talking
about
not just within any held expression
okay so that won't work
this won't
work
okay
but this
the map
of immediate binding
of funk
whoops
comma list will work
yeah and that is different from
[Music]
so we've got two different things which
we've got map of immediate evaluate
of func
comma list which goes much further
so immediate evaluate
among other things does immediate
binding
correct yes
it has to but it goes further
exactly
and the only difference between them is
if list isn't really a list
but is a held
object
right well i mean
i mean if it isn't a held object then
both of these are equivalent to the just
funk
right except subtly you know internally
it may be different i mean like i said
before you could avoid memory blow up or
things like that
wait wait you're saying even if list
evaluates
this would be different semantically
right because the way the way map is
implemented is it creates all the
expressions and then sends it sends the
whole big result back to the evaluator
so immediate evaluate would would
evaluate each time the function is done
which is sub it's it's subtly different
but it is different
yeah and if map ever had different
traversal orders this would also
be different it'd be evaluating there
might be side effect-y things that would
actually behave
right
yes i mean the things you just said
rob about about is actually a pretty
interesting feature
so okay ian
traversal orders
right
okay so basically what would happen is
if there's a side effect
right so the traversal order if if we
have a map of funk
onto a list in some weird traversal
order
we will not see that traversal order
in fact we will never see the traversal
order
because funk will never start getting
evaluated
until
all of the
until it's been sprayed everywhere by
map
correct
um
that's sort of unexpected i mean in a
sense with a traversal order you might
expect an immediate evaluate there
um
be more like scan
scan doesn't need to evaluate does scan
do immediate evaluate
i think scan
it doesn't create the whole data
structure
i i don't know the implementation that
seems to be the behavior
okay
since scan is calling evaluate yes
yeah i think scan house has to call
everywhere and the function is so scan
is is immediate evaluation
throws the thing away so
right there's nothing to return
i see whereas map thinks it's not
wasting anything by just creating
everything and then calling the
evaluator
right and that allows certain up values
to work and things like this
okay so this is changing
well i mean
i'm sorry
fold is also eagerly evaluating
okay
so for scan and fold
so you're saying for scan and fold
immediate evaluate does nothing
so yes
but there is a question i mean there are
three things a media evaluate could do
sit there unevaluated
melt away
or actually do something
we should do the first or the last
sorry what would that what i'm sorry i
missed something what what what what's
the question i mean okay so what does
immediate evaluate immediately has three
possible behaviors if you type it in on
the top level of you know it just does
nothing
right
mm-hmm
okay that's case number one
case number two
it does its job like in map
okay case number three is something like
scan
where there is no job for it to do
and we presumably want it to melt away
you know what i'm saying we don't want
it to to fail to work and to stay
unevaluated and scan we want it to be as
if it was there but just didn't happen
to do anything
well we could all we could say it should
behave like that it should trigger an
extra level of
vowel
that's fine that's fine we could do that
but my point is that though even those
functions which automatically do
immediately evaluate
need to have some behavior with
immediate evaluate
you get what i'm saying
sure
absolutely
um
right so we need an inventory i don't
think i don't i don't think fold
evaluates as it goes do we have proof of
that
right if if you do if you fold over a
held thing i think it prints
i think it has to because because it has
to get the intermediate results to for
the next application
if otherwise you create these huge
symbols
yeah which i think which i think is what
happened
no
i think that's
evaluating as it goes along
oh we
tell that has to be it just has to be i
think it has to be
yeah i think i think nest nest and nest
list also evaluate as they go
yeah okay in any case in any case that
that's a so in those things it is
essentially a no-op
correct
but it would still get stripped
whereas if it's just the function foo
it's not going to get stripped
see what i'm saying yeah
so one thing we need here is an
inventory of what functions we think are
going to
uh sort of do something with the media
evaluator either strip it or use it
that makes sense you're right yeah so i
mean obvious right obvi the obvious
cases are map map at and probably
replace part
yeah but god knows subset map and you
know all these tons of other ones
have all kinds of behaviors
okay
so
i'm a little troubled by the immediate
evaluate versus evaluate
um
and this binding thing and by the way
immediate evaluate of immediate binding
of funk
should presumably melt away
correct
understand what i'm saying
presumably
okay
well
i think we should try implementing this
these two things
what do other people think
right i mean the one thing about
immediate development i mean i i don't
necessarily object to that i you know
one set of issues which we haven't
discussed relate to
um
you know if you use immediate evaluating
rule
or i guess rule delayed really is the
interesting case
um
you know how does that
combine with you know condition and
right because you can have all these
various combinations of conditions in
various places and
but
we'll just i guess we'll just have to
work through that but i'm just saying
that i'm not i'm not it's not obvious to
me what should happen now
yeah exactly
yeah right i'm just pointing out that
there is an issue we have a design issue
we haven't discussed that many i'm sure
there are many as we go as we go through
this we look at actual functions and
what they do and things like map that
seem to have i i don't know what happens
when they're there
you know i can imagine a weird the weird
possibility of an immediate evaluate no
i i cannot imagine the following
where
there are multiple
arguments and you want one of them to be
inserted through binding and the other
one not tough luck can't do that you get
what i'm saying like
um
a map indexed
or a supplied for that matter
where there are multiple
parameters that should be bound
did you understand the scenario
you're saying that the immediate
substitute shouldn't work immediate
binding i'm saying i'm saying if you've
got three values
that could be immediately bound it is
not self-evident you would always want
to immediately bind either none of them
or all of them
um
yeah it's not worth it it's not worth it
it's irrelevant
yeah um
and most of the time it's gonna be a
single argument anyway
yeah i mean i guess a question we should
answer before we try to do so where
where does immediate binding appear it
appears
around a function in things like map and
it appears on the
right hand side of rules do we allow
other places no no no no we don't need
it in the right-hand side of rules
because rules are automatically
immediate binding
i might immediately evaluate um for that
case
okay yes
yes
and i'm sure there are 17 other cases
which we have not immediately thought of
here
which is what we have to go through
i'm not sure what this is evaluation
during er evil evaluation during that
that that's uh
that that i mean that's
uh i mean that this is another issue to
to discuss
um
i mean you you skipped over we we
skipped over the supplied
um
thing and and i just uh well i mean
we've got
not everybody here was in the meeting
well i i'm not sure that i'm not
convinced that we've solved that but
certainly not everybody here was on that
previous meeting so people should be
right uh
so
well are we doing
so what yes
well so so one question is
well i guess so one question is do you
agree with this summary here of
um you know are we implementing all of
these
you know both environment variables and
supplied one of them
etc
but yes
i think we definitely
want i think if the environment
variables are semantically well defined
which i'm not 100 on
i think they're pretty nice
i'm just a little worried that they may
be semantically confusing
that's what we want so so you think we
should start so you think we should
start with supplied rather than the
environment variables
well but supply is here using the
environment variable and where you've
set it up
um
well i think that was my understanding
that we were going to use that right
instead of strings but if we want to use
strings for now
language use strengths i mean for
supplied because the supplied is going
to give an association isn't it
no so the the association thing is is
not needed if we have these actual
environment variable symbols
so supplied would be this two argument
thing that's just for wrapping an
expression around a sequence of
expressions
why does i don't understand that first
thing the supply of dollar dollar
position comma f
that's simply saying feed to f
not only his expression but also
right whereas if you wanted to only see
the position yeah you wrap it in a list
right so so so the the the the
convention was
if if it's a singleton
if if if it's not a list then you you
add that thing to whatever is the normal
list of things for that right in
particular this object is like having a
function function which pulls in one of
its arguments from the outside world or
from the environment basically right
that's what this is doing yes so i mean
the name
right so i think rob was there for this
discussion but maybe not tom and mark so
i just thought well supplying might be
better in this case maybe
um
look you know the other thing is we
could ligaturize dollar dollar in some
way to make it a little bit more
attractive
but i think that's i mean that's pretty
nice particularly if it's ligaturized
and looks better
i think that's a pretty nice thing
programming wise
what do other people think
well yeah i think it's very nice but but
we have to be we'll have to be pretty
explicit on where
you know in in what environments
does it does it work
yes
well it's the same deal that we've got
with immediate evaluating immediate
binding this is all pretty much yeah
it's quite similar
right
you know we live in environmentally
conscious times what can i say
um
yeah
um
and and in a sense
i'm i'm sorry i'm not going to extend
this pun too much further about saving
the environment in these variables
um
never mind i don't think it does much
for the
uh
okay immediate evaluate would save some
cpu burning okay um
all right i think i need to go but uh
okay
i think with that please let's go ahead
and try and do some implementation of
these things i think they're going to be
a bunch of bumps i think going to be a
bunch of weird cases and issues yep
but let's let's at least start
and
yeah right so i think i think ian has a
true in a branch a trial implementation
of supplied for
is it ma tree map i think or pre-map and
tree scan
how does it feel which is still
well so it's
extending the behavior that we had for
we were doing like level spec aero data
level spec arrow subtree no i'm asking
you when you've used it does it seem
like it's a good design
yeah
yes
good
all right places for trees are going to
be nest tree tree fold and then the
vision i understand that's not what i'm
asking i'm asking i'm asking you know
when you've actually implemented it and
you try using it is it like oh my gosh
this is crazy and the answer is no so
far
right but so let's get it into some more
you know more familiar functions like
map and so on and let's see how it feels
there
all right i get a wrap um
okay
good stuff thanks guys
um
see you later